hi there everyone I'm an East Midlands
Airport just outside Nottingham and
shortly I'm getting on a plane to fly
north in the hope of seeing the Northern
Lights we're not landing or going to the
snow or anything we're just going to fly
then do a u-turn and come back now the
weather above is cloudy that's not a
problem of course because we're going to
be flying above the clouds for what is a
problem is the space weather which isn't
looking too good the solar activity is
not too high so we might not be in luck
only one way to find out let's go and
catch this flight fingers crossed we're
going to go up to the edge of the
northern edge of UK airspace to try and
peek at the auroral oval which should be
glowing towards the north now what we've
done is brought everybody into the
departure lounge of East Midlands
Airport and we are going to give them a
presentation an hour's presentation on
the Stars they can see up there plus
what causes the aurora and the Sun
effect basically an interaction with the
Earth's magnetic field and then we're
going to get on board the aircraft we're
going to fly towards the North hopefully
turn the well no we won't hopefully we
will turn the lights off and give
everybody about 20 minutes dark adaption
time before we actually get to our point
north and the plane will fly backwards
and forwards doing a racetrack pattern
and people on one side of the aircraft
will turn at they will see a view
towards the north if we see the aurora
that's brilliant
but you've got no guarantee with that
but the stars are fantastic up there the
Milky Way looks spectacular when you see
out of the plane window
so I'm quite
your eyes actually undergoing chemical
reaction now I am becoming back to more
sensitive and outside there's great
views of the stars they'll get you
better as your eyes get fully
dark-adapted you can see the features
but it is certainly visible yes I
considered my trade now I know a parent
structure in it but you can certainly
see the suspension bridge effect where
he's arching over very slowly guide your
two films and movies
it is an incredible atmosphere because
there are three people either side of
the plane and in order for people to be
able to see out of the window there has
to be a sort of Aurora shuffle if you
like where the people at the window then
moved to the aisle and vice versa so
they all have to get up and so there's a
community spirit I think and everybody's
very excited about it and what happens
is we tell them to do that right the
very beginning of the flight and after a
while they just wanted their own natural
rhythm to do it and I think people make
great friends on these flights as a
consequence of that we go exact graphics
oh my word yeah this is the aurora
though I just begin to pray sometimes
you can see that
one is bright conversational in their
look putting on the mountain roller
sheeter
to your photo because I've got my camera
my camera's been adjusted for dark
flying's it's got a red cellophane cover
over here if I showed you the motors
have got there that's not bad
so we've got the red glow on the top and
we've also got the green get me in there
so that's the main Aurora if you go a
bit later in the display if I won't
forward a bit you can see that there is
a bit of structure there so there's a
way starting to form and that wanna
consume the stars get a bit blurry on
the flights because it's a moving
platform there's a 30 second exposures
it's still a fairly weak display I have
to say I mean we have we have displays
which are so intense that you can look
down the aircraft at people's faces look
green because the oil is glowing and
we're always badgering the flight deck
to go as far north as as possible and
we've had one flight it was out of
Bristol where we went as far north as
possible and it was such an active
aurora that we were actually underneath
it they're all oval had spread out and
we had to go in and say please can you
go a bit further south because we can't
see it's above us so if you can never
tell what's happening with the Aurora's
it's just so unpredictable that's one of
the beauties of it really